[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana un programa
de radio internacional y de France 24
esta semana ponemos los focos en Brasil
en víspera de unas elecciones que
enfrentan al izquierdista Lula da Silva
frente al presidente el ultraderechista
Yair bolsonaro nos acompañan en este
estudio David gormezano periodista en
France 24 que fue corresponsal en Brasil
bienvenido David Hola Carlos Paloma
barón politóloga y compañera de la
redacción brasileña de recibo bienvenida
Paloma Gracias y el periodista
especializado en Latinoamérica guilló
mascar y bienvenido guillón Buenos días
Brasil áspero Duelo entre Lula contra
bolsonaro hoy en Primera Plana
[Música]
a primera vista el duelo en las
elecciones brasileñas del 2 de octubre
pudiese parecer clásico entre derecha e
izquierda en Latinoamérica Pero hay
varios actores que invitan a no pensarlo
dos viejos conocidos con largos
historiales que forman parte de la
polarización extrema el ánimo de
votantes en la contienda y sobre todo el
temor ante las reacciones del
imprevisible presidente el
ultraderechista brasileño bolsonaro En
caso de que pierda añaden incertidumbre
a estos comicios a doble vuelta donde de
nuevo la desinformación en redes
sociales fenómeno conocido en Brasil el
voto religioso y la violencia política
son parte de la cita electoral repasemos
algunas portadas que nos deja la cita
voy a de Sao Paulo reproducía uno de los
últimos sondeos esta semana Lula 45%
bolsonaro 33% para la primera vuelta el
2 de octubre este porcentaje habría
aumentado en las últimas horas al 47% a
favor de Lula aquí en Francia también
deja traza las portadas de esta elección
como esta que vende el diario El
Liberación que titula la democracia en
juego y que afirma que pese a que
encabeza los sondeos la batalla no está
ganada para Lula para terminar esta
portada algo anterior de Time del mes de
mayo pasado bajo el titular Lula segundo
acto bueno si les parece vamos a
explicarlo Primero estamos de forma
didáctica David estamos ante una primera
vuelta la del 2 de octubre pero yo
tenemos un cartel entre dos candidatos
el izquierdista Lula y
bolsonaro porque si estamos ante una
primera vuelta para que nos entiendan
los espectadores estamos ya ante un
juego de dos bueno son los dos
personajes más importantes de la bebida
política de Brasil en los últimos años
bolsonaro fue electado en el 2018 en un
contexto muy especial
Lula era un ex presidente encarcelado
entonces este Duelo es bueno es lo que
parece Inevitable Inevitable y todos los
otros candidatos porque hay hay algunos
11 no en total 11 hay dentro de estos 11
años son dos que están encima de 5% de
la intención de votos Pero toda la
campaña desde casi un año está
polarizada entre Lula y bolsonaro son
dos personajes bueno
nula 50 años que está un personaje
central en la vida política
de Brasil divorcionado tiene una carrera
en el parlamento en el congreso de
Brasil de 30 años antes de ser
presidente dos pesos pesados de la
política brasileña que polarizan también
a la sociedad luego les quiero preguntar
sobre el clima de violencia política que
se ha establecido en Brasil pero antes
sondeos Lula lidera con un 47% las
últimas encuestas es posible que gane ya
en la primera vuelta del 2 de octubre o
esta posibilidad no le dais por
verosímil Paloma Yo creo que sí porque
en la última encuesta datafolia dice que
estaba con 47% Entonces dos puntos
personales a más que que la encuesta
anterior y vos sonaron mantiene su 33%,
para ganar una elección en Brasil en
candidato necesita de 50 del 50% de los
votos válidos más uno
ya tiene
de acuerdo con esta encuesta el 50%
entonces
existe una posibilidad
Por qué no se ha consolidado una tercera
vía es decir aquí hablamos un
enfrentamiento muy claro entre dos pesos
pesados de la política brasileña entre
medias no hay nada en esta primera
vuelta sí existe una tercera vía o sea
se ofrece o sea Ciro Gómez que se ofrece
como una tercera vía pero es una tercera
vía Porque él fue ministro de de Lula
justamente pero no no es una tercera vía
que es significativa yo creo por por los
brasileños porque hoy día el partido se
juega entre Lula y bolsonaro y se podía
jugar también en 2018 no sé el partido
al final no se hizo en 2018 ahora en
2022 se va a hacer este partido que
muchos brasileños esperan entre dos uno
el mandatario actual y el ex presidente
Lula que tuvo dos mandatos donde vamos
ingresar también en este tema que que
también con con éxitos sobre todo por la
economía también brasileños luego
hablaremos de esos balances pero a
diferencia de elecciones anteriores
David en que los contendientes se veían
podemos aplicar la palabra adversario
político ahora hablamos más bien de
enemigo político entre dos figuras que
polarizan a la sociedad brasileña de ahí
este clima de violencia que se ha
instalado en Brasil hace cinco o seis
años que Brasil entró en un ciclo de
crisis de crisis económica
la economía de Brasil está no está
creciendo más y hubo momentos de de de
de de de de muy difícil para para muchos
brasileños en los últimos años y hay una
crisis política también hubo la
destitución de una presidenta hubo la
encarcelación de un ex presidente
ganó un candidato en el 2018 que no
viene de los partidos que han
estructurado la vida política brasileña
desde el regreso a la democracia en el
Entonces el Brasil ha entrado en un
periodo
inédita de su de su historia
y y estamos ahora en un momento clave
creo yo creo que
gana quien gana esa esta crisis política
es este extremismo que que viene de una
parte conservadora
del electorado brasileño no va a parar
con el resultado con esta elección claro
tres de cada cuatro lectores brasileños
dice sentir temor por expresar sus ideas
políticas en este momento
estos se palpa en allí hay temor a la
política sí sobre todo porque desde que
evolucionaron fue bolsonaro fue elegido
la violencia política que claro no es
normal pero fue legitimizada en esta
campaña está más fuerte porque un día ha
dicho
las personas pueden sus armas para
defender la política en un otro día un
militante del partido de los
trabajadores el partido de Lula fue
muerto Entonces ese screamers empieza a
acontecer más y más en Brasil en 2018
antes de la elección del personal
tuvimos el asesinato de la de María Eli
Franco que era concejal por Río de
Janeiro después en los cuatro años
siguientes hubo un aumento del 33% en la
violencia contra las mujeres en la
política y no solo las mujeres
recientemente antes de la fecha Nacional
de Brasil de ese templo el hijo de
bolsonaro Eduardo bolsonaro ha dicho
también que los ciudadanos que tienen el
porte legal de armas de bien salir a las
calles para defender
abozonaron Entonces sí claro cuando el
presidente sus hijos y su círculo
próximo defienden que que la violencia
es posible es más fácil si eso ocurre
más es como ver este clima de violencia
que se instalado yo creo que en Brasil
hay una violencia de sociedad y ahora
Hay una violeza que que aumentó durante
esas elecciones y sobre todo durante Esa
esa elección que que se está viviendo
todo desde meses en Brasil y y el clima
de inseguridad que hay en Brasil no es
no es solo en las grandes ciudades no es
solo en la favelas pero si no va más
allá de eso va más allá de la cirología
de lo que puede ser el evolucionarismo y
y también o lo que puede ser también lo
que Lula es una violencia que es
generalizada en Brasil hoy día y que
vemos justamente también en la prensa
cada día en Brasil la prensa que que
habla de asesinato justamente en julio
por ejemplo en el en foz de iguazú en
Brasil con con un representante del
partido de los trabajadores de Lula que
fue asesinato por la policía otra de las
claves de esta batalla electoral el voto
religioso que parece consolidarse como
la Gran Batalla de estos comicios se
trata del 90% de 150 millones de
votantes registrados en el país ambos
candidatos dicen que es Dios quien les
guía estas apelaciones constantes que
repercusiones tienen en un país como
Brasil David
Brasil es un país religioso pero yo creo
que
Lula en cada de sus campañas electorales
intentó
seducir al voto evangélico pero
Lula viene no viene de una tradición muy
religiosa es un sindicalista
siempre fue en los años 80s y noventas
fue próximo a unos pensadores de la de
la teología de la liberación
el católico sí o no el voto católico
está dividido
quizás menos
en sentido diferente del voto evangélico
Pero hay católicos que votan a la
izquierda hay católicos que votan a la
derecha Gerardo admin el candidato avise
de Lula es alguien es un católico
conservador y era candidato de derecha
en elecciones previas en Brasil por
ejemplo como ven esta batalla por el
voto religioso que ha llevado incluso a
que la primera dama Michelle
bolsonaro se posiciona en campaña no
haga campaña por ese voto evangélico tan
que es fundamental No sí es fundamental
pero los evangélicos no son la mayoría
en Brasil el 56% de la población se
declara católica Entonces el voto
católico es más importante pero claro
que los evangélicos que representan unos
26 a 30% de la población también son un
voto importante y la mayoría de los
evangélicos están convulsionados los
católicos es de acuerdo con la última
encuesta datafolia el 53%
con bolsonaro en Brasil Sí es muy
importante porque los evangélicos
neuquén de costales son grupos muy
Unidos muy firme y muy conservador
entonces en Michelle evolucionaron la
primera dama representa eso
creo que todo fue fue dicho yo pienso
que la iglesia es muy importante en
América Latina y sobre todo en Brasil
durante las elecciones vimos la
importancia de la iglesia y justamente
las últimas reuniones que se hicieron
del lado de bolsonaro con Lula se
hicieron también en iglesia para para
buscar apoyos Entonces se va a jugar
también ahí también las elecciones
a una pausa para vuelta de pausa
hablaremos del voto femenino pero
también de la desinformación y de las
Sombras que encierran y que afectan
ambos candidatos será enseguida aquí en
Primera Plana hasta ahora
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en francés 24 y France 24.com
Tenemos aquí en Primera Plana esta
semana analizando las elecciones de
Brasil del próximo 2 de octubre ese
Duelo entre Jair bolsonario y Lula da
Silva lo hacemos con los periodistas
David gómezzano Paloma barón y guillón
ascari una elección tan polarizada que
no sé si la podemos analizar como una
disputa de rechazos los que generan
ambos candidatos tanto bolsonaro como
Lula son comparables los rechazos que
ambos suscitan en una parte de la
población y yo yo no creo porque ahí son
dos personalidades bien diferentes
entonces este hay que ver también del
lado de evolucionado una ideología que
yo creo que hay ellos que son por
bolsonaro y el Antiguo sonaron y Y eso
cuenta mucho en la elección hoy día Lula
Regresa con una una que es totalmente
diferente a sus antiguas campañas con
una imagen de Brasil Que es bien
diferente de lo que ofrece y propone
bolsonaro Entonces yo pienso que rechazo
va va a aprovechar más de rechazo que
que evolucionaron porque la imagen de
Brasil durante esos últimos años y peor
con la pandemia fue fue bien malogrado
pero en cualquier caso Sí David sí que
hay una parte de Brasil Que odia a Lula
profundamente también al odio anula el
odio a la izquierda que que existe en
Brasil desde los últimos años es
impresionante
yo parece que mucha gente ha olvidado el
personal es un producto de ello podemos
decir de Ese odio
vosotros en profesional del odio desde
que entró en política es es un personaje
que que tiene odio
él defiende a la dictadura militar y
[Música]
siempre tuvo un modo de expresión muy
violento desde desde que inició su
carrera política es su es su marca es su
leme en la política pero
unos años atrás el Brasil no está Tonto
por el polarizado había alternencia
entre entre el pez bebé y el PT hubo una
década al 2000 muy exitosa por Brasil
una tasa de crecimiento increíble
la imagen exterior que proyectaba a
Brasil al mundo también era muy distinta
de la que tiene ahora el país No pero
mucha gente
y había olvidado que existe un Brasil
un poco desconocido al menos en Europa
muy conservador muy muy religioso y
y que
y que ahora está tomando el control del
debate político Yo creo que es lo que
pasó en los últimos años porque no
éramos conscientes
fuera de Brasil de que también existía
ese otro Brasil Que odiaba a Lula que
emergía y que llegó finalmente al poder
no éramos tan conscientes de que existía
Yo creo que es este Brasil tenía una
expresión
menos
con menos poder con números extenso
en los últimos años
Quizás vamos a hablar de defeng news y
de la importancia de redes sociales
es el instrumento catalizador yo creo
que que sí que que el odio a Lula
existaba antes pero que se hizo algo
central en el debate público eso es
gracias a los a las redes sociales y
gracias a la crisis política que
iniciada en el 2015 por las
investigaciones de la operación lavayato
que cambió mucho el debate político
también en Brasil la desinformación en
redes sociales ya lo vimos en la campaña
anterior Pero sigue siendo Brasil un
país abonado a las fake news a través
del WhatsApp Paloma sí sí sí sí sí no se
han puesto mecanismos para controlar
por ejemplo
contesta todas las encuestas y dice que
existe un Data pueblo pueblo porque
cuando viaja cuando está con el pueblo
siente que va a ganar y que va a ganar
en primero turno cuando fue a los
funerales de la reina en Londres ha
hecho un discurso de la embajada de
Brasil hace un político en La Tribuna de
la ONU en el funeral de Isabel II donde
le pille el señor de Brasil Entonces
debería estar como presidente
y eso no puede ser confundido en Brasil
hay una ley electoral que dice que
cuando estás como presidente no puede
hacer campaña política pero él no
respeta así como no respeta la creación
de las fake news en la en WhatsApp en
las redes entonces habla del Data pueblo
que es su propia su un punto de
encuestas y también hay casos ya
registrados de que
ponen
encuestas que no existen en La Voz del
presentador de John nacional que es el
más importante John al televisivo de
Brasil una encuesta que no existe
Perdón Es cierto que las mentiras
también han llegado a televisión
alcanzando a otros públicos Lula ha
firmado haber sido absuelto de todos los
procesos que enfrentaban en relación con
la macrooperación anticorrupción la
bayato pero en realidad esto es falso
porque las condenas fueron anuladas en
buena parte por problemas procesales
esto no le pasa factura a Lula
yo creo que que Lula en esta elección el
su problema es es repetir las campañas
de antes yo creo que
la la izquierda tiene
hubiera querido un otro candidato que
Lula pero que no existe entonces Lula es
candidato Pero por qué no emerge porque
no pueden emerger otros candidatos
porque considerando todo el pasado y los
procesos de Lula hubiese sido más normal
que otro candidato hubiera podido llegar
en la izquierda por qué no se permite
una renovación como pasa por ejemplo en
Chile con borich porque no sale otra
figura de la izquierda porque sabemos la
importancia en América Latina de tener
cargos políticos y cuando miramos en los
11 candidatos quien tiene cargos
políticos ha tenido cargos políticos
responsabilidades Contamos con tres
Contamos con Lula Contamos con bolsonaro
o fuera de ser senador o diputados y
contamos Gómez Entonces el Brasil Brasil
tiene tiene que tener una figura y hoy
día no no hermeje una una otra figura
que que nula y yo pienso También que la
izquierda hubiera también gustado tener
otra otra otras posibilidades que Lula
Quizás por la pobreza Yo pienso que
también otro tema es la imagen exterior
de Brasil que parece haberse degradado
en estos cuatro años de gestión de por
sonaro de esto se habla también en
campaña o es una campaña ensimismada en
luchas internas se habla de la imagen
que proyecta Brasil al exterior Paloma
se habla poco pero sí la izquierda habla
porque es importante para la izquierda
mostrada que enseñar que cuando uno le
estaba en el poder Lula viajaba todo el
mundo era recibido por todos los líderes
fue el único que cuando la reina murió
fue el único que pudo publicar fotos con
la reina Porque ha encontrado la reina
la otra vez y vos sonar como no podía
hacer eso fue a los Entonces sí es
importante la imagen en el exterior
claro
ayer la ministra del supremo tribunal
Carmen Rusia ha hablado de eso de la
violencia política de la violencia
cultural y cómo y que la cultura de
Brasil de las cosas que más es más
importante o que podemos estar
orgullosos de eso también en el exterior
y que hoy hay censura Entonces sí es una
imagen que está decadencia completa y la
izquierda habla mucho de eso su machismo
su rechazo minoría su gestión de la
pandemia los insultos la mala imagen que
proyecta internacionalmente de todo el
balance que es lo que más lastra la
figura de bolsonaro
qué es lo que más se le reprocha de todo
lo que tiene el señor para mí él es el
papel de los militares en los cuatro
años de bolsonaro es un hito en el en la
historia de Brasil después de 25 años de
casi silencio
el ejército brasileño salió de nuevo
como un protagonista muy importante
en el país hasta un tercio de los
ministros eran militares
seis mil militares tienen puestos en la
administración y ahora el ejército
quiere ser el árbitro de esta elección
está hablando de un sistema de conteo
paralelo porque ha habido mucha polémica
con este tema y
y por ahora está el supremo tribunal no
quiere que existe un conteo paralelo
pero
el ejército está diciendo los brasileños
nosotros vamos a hacer el arbitraje
entre Lula y bolsonaro Y esto es es un
hito el miedo a un golpe de bolsonaro es
algo con lo que ha especulado bastante
la prensa internacional el miedo a no
reconocer los resultados o a sus
reacciones si sale perdedor Cuánta
veracidad otorgan a que algo pueda hacer
el presidente brasileño si pierde las
elecciones y yo no creo a
al hecho que evolucionaron bueno igual
va a ser un poco como reflejo
de Trump no le va a reconocer Pero al
final le va a tener que reconocer y
mostró durante esos últimos días a
moderado su discurso por ejemplo a nivel
delante de los evangelistas diciendo que
iba a reconocer este los resultados yo
creo que va a ser complicado y que la
sociedad seguir a polarizada como como
está Y quizás más fuerte pero al final
va a tener que reconocer si pierde esa
elección que todavía no
está por venir hemos hablado de los
militares antes hablábamos del rechazo
de bolsonaro a las minorías Y en este
contexto podemos decir que el voto
femenino está decididamente inclinado a
favor de Lula Paloma las mujeres el 49%
de las mujeres
dicen que van a votar por Lula contra
29% por bolsonaro en 2018 las mujeres
tuvieron papel importante hicieron una
campaña que se decía él no era el
eslogan de las mujeres pero no fue
suficiente cuatro años después
las mujeres somos mayoría en Brasil
entonces más son más personas que votan
y están tal vez más conscientes que los
ataques aquí a las mujeres que hace
bozonaron y que recientemente
cambiar su discurso pero no es
suficiente entonces sí las mujeres están
son en cualquier caso sea uno u otro
hablamos de dos señores mayores que
proyectan signos arcaicos y pocas
renovación por no hablar de historiales
con sombras tiene Brasil un problema con
hacer emerger figuras que representen
más a la sociedad de hoy en día que
estén más conectadas con sensibilidades
actuales de los jóvenes David sí es Eso
es cierto pero del lado
de Lula
Lula es un es un de golf
brasileño
la
su década del poder
impactó mucho
la sociedad brasileña
es difícil de cuando tienes un personaje
tan importante es es luchó contra La
dictadura y fue presente en todas las
elecciones
presidenciales en Brasil desde la caída
de Dictadura es difícil él tiene un
reemplazarlo
Muchísimas gracias a los tres ha sido un
placer y a todos ustedes les espero la
semana que viene aquí en Primera Plana
gracias
[Música]